let's see if we can take the indefinite
integral of sine squared X cosine to the
third X DX and like always pause the
video and see if you can work it through
on your own alright so right when you
look at it you're like oh wow if this
was just a sine of X not a sine squared
of X well that's going to be the
derivative of the derivative of cosine
of X maybe I could abuse u-substitution
likewise if this was just a cosine of X
not a cosine to the third of X I could
have used u substitution I could have
said u is equal to sine of X but I can't
do that over here and so the general
idea is here if you have if one of these
has an odd exponent and you see that
this one does have an odd x one the
cosine has an odd exponent what you do
is you try to engineer algebraically
engineer this expression side so that
you can use u substitution the way that
you can do that if you have an odd
exponent like this is to separate out
one of the cosines X and then use the
Pythagorean theorem a and identity with
the remaining cosine squared X so what
do I mean by that so let me just rewrite
this so this can be rewritten as sine
squared X times let me write it this way
times cosine squared X cosine X oh it is
I rewrote something to the third power
something to the second power times that
thing to the first power DX DX and then
this can be rewritten as sine squared X
and then I'm going to use the
Pythagorean identity to convert this
into a sine squared or a really one
minus sine squared so that by the
Pythagorean identity is the same thing
as 1 minus sine squared X and then we
have cosine X times cosine X DX DX and
now I can distribute this sine squared
times 1 minus sine squared and I am left
with so all of let me do this in a new
color so this business right here so now
I'm left with the indefinite integral of
so sine squared X times 1
is going to be sine squared X and then
sine squared x times negative sine
squared X is negative sine to the fourth
and then all of that times cosine X all
of that times cosine X DX now this is
starting to look interesting because I
have sine squared X minus sine of the
fourth X but I have the derivative of
sine sitting out here I have cosine X
that's the whole reason why we did this
little algebraic manipulation and so you
substitution works out quite well now
because if we say if we said that let me
do another color I'll do purple if we
say that U is equal to sine is equal to
sine of X then D U then D U is going to
be equal to cosine of X DX and that
works out quite well because we have the
D U right over here and then this would
be u squared minus U to the fourth which
we know how to take the antiderivative
of so we're in the homestretch so we can
rewrite this as the indefinite integral
instead of sine squared X we're saying
sine is the same thing as u so we can
rewrite that as you can rewrite that as
u squared minus minus U to the fourth
times D u times D u and this is pretty
straightforward now this is going to be
u to the third over 3 minus U to the
fifth over five plus c plus plus C and
then we just do the reverse substitution
and then that gets us to be instead of U
we want to put a sine of X there so
we're going to get sine to the third X
or sine of X to the third over 3 minus
sine of X to the fifth power write that
five a little bit sine of X to the fifth
power over five plus C and we
are done